hi everybody
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you here today
to the final installment for this
semester in our special
benjamin and barbara zucker lecture
series dedicated to exploring the
connections
between anti-semitism and other forms of
racism
and prejudice today we're especially
fortunate to have with us
terence l johnson terence is associate
professor
of religion and politics in the
department of government
at georgetown university where he's also
an affiliate faculty member
of the department of african american
studies
and senior faculty fellow at the
berkeley center for religion
peace and world affairs his research
interests include
african-american political thought
american religions religion and public
life
and ethics he's the author of we testify
with our lives
how religion transformed radical thought
from black power
to black lives matter which is about to
be published by columbia university
press in 2021
he's also the co-author of the
forthcoming blacks and jews
an introduction to a dialogue which is
going to be published by georgetown
university press also
in 2021 he's also the author of
tragic soul life w.e.b du bois and the
moral crisis facing american democracy
published by oxford in 2012. his essays
have appeared in a number of edited
volumes and journals
including the journal of religious
ethics journal of africana religions
cross currents and the journal of the
society
of christian ethics johnson is also the
co-editor of the religious
cultures of african and african diaspora
diaspora people book series
which is published by duke university
press
now the way it'll work today is that um
terence will speak for about 30 minutes
and then we'll have the chance to ask
him questions for another
30 minutes so please submit your
questions
anytime using the q a function at the
bottom
of the screen so you're welcome to
submit the questions during the talk
and i will filter i'll ask him the
questions that you submit to me
um during the the talk and after
um i won't be seeing raised hand uh
or and we won't be using the the chat
function so please only use the q
a um so the title of terence's talk
today
is grounds for hope blacks jews and the
future of democracy
please join me in silently welcoming
terence l
johnson great thank you so much uh
professor mark
maurice samuels it's an honor to be here
um
i'd like to thank the el program for the
study of anti-semitism for this
opportunity to share my work
on blacks and jews and a special thank
you to anessa
laskova for managing the minor and major
details
of the student discussion
so i come today um really with
i would say a slightly heavy heart in
part because
when i initially started teaching this
course on blacks and jews in america
with two colleagues at haverford college
back in
2009 it was really more of a kind of
intellectual sort of theoretical
pursuit to explore how history
religion ethics sort of overlap and
overlap with this particular set of
individuals or ethnic groups within the
u.s
but something changed um after trump's
election
and with um the charlottesville
protests in 2016.
and as we sort of think about this
moment in terms of
what changed for me intellectually and
personally i would like to
just have a moment of silence to
remember those who were murdered
at mother emanuel amy church in 2015 in
the tree of life synagogue in 2018
both groups were murdered because they
were black
or because they were jewish
taiwanza sanders reverend sharonda
coleman singleton
revan clementa pickney cynthia hurd
myra thompson reverend depayne middleton
doctor
susie jackson ethel lance
reverend daniel simmons joyce feinberg
richard gottfried rose mallinger
jerry rabinowitz cesa rosenthal
david rosenthal bernice simon
sylvan simon daniel stein
melvin wax and irving
younger
and how do we get here when i first
heard of
the united right rally in
charlottesville
i assumed it would be a host of
characters
protesting immigration um
those you know illegally entering the
borders
or some something to do with gay
marriage
this idea that you know liberals are
taking over democracy
but i was shocked right when i
discovered
that at the very heart of the rally
was about anti-blackness and
anti-semitism
and as my colleague jacques bellumbaugh
talked this over
after we watched this horrific clip we
were stunned
by what we discovered and i want to take
us back to that moment
so someone more capable like donald
trump
who does not give his daughter
to a jew
so when we think about blacks and jews
in america
often this iconic picture emerges in our
mind
right of rabbi abraham heshow and king
walking arm in arm and selma in 1963
and we think of the whole idea of a
grand alliance right
this idea of blacks and jews fighting
arm and arm against social um unrest
fighting against anti-anti-black racism
anti-semitism
and we think of a very harmonious group
and then we think of a big explosion
happening in 67 with the emergence of
israel
and and and this whole idea of black
power
invoking black independence and then
really in some ways frightening jews and
put and pushing many of the jew jewish
members of snake
out of the organization to build a kind
of sort of self-reliant group
and that is sort of the kind of the
narrative we often hear about but i want
to argue
that the story is far more complicated
and while i won't get all the details
tonight
i want to argue that it's complicated in
part because someone like adolf reed is
going to argue that
there are many different types of
relationships between blacks and jews we
have
elite blacks and jews working hand in
hand right
at the turn of the 20th century with the
founding of the naacp
and we and also blacks and jews working
with the urban league
right and these are african-americans
and and jews who
are you know part of sort of the
establishment as it were
and if not a part of the establishment
definitely on the trajectory right of
the middle class
sort of um ideology really thinking
through
how do we work together right to
solidify our rights as citizens
but also how do we work together to end
segregation and anti-semitism and all
the barriers right to achieving the
so-called american dream
so that's one aspect of the story the
other aspect of the story really has to
do with
um you know day workers right
and sort of you know uh jewish merchants
who
are are often engaged in businesses you
know because of segregation at the time
permanently they were forced to work in
black communities and so there's another
relationship between
jewish merchants and say
african-american working-class
individuals
and also african-american women who are
day workers working within
jewish homes so we have these sort of
two-tiered kinds of relationships
and so part of what i'm trying to do in
part
as a result of charlottesville is sort
of rethink why is this
material important to me and part of why
i think it's important is because i
think there's something
in terms within the kind of the
infighting
within the the sort of the solidarity
movements uh between the groups
that we can actually glean to help us
think about public deliberation
to help us really rethink what is
political solidarity and also to help us
to rethink you know what are the grounds
for understanding religion
and sort of cross-religious sort of
dialogue
so i want to put forth uh an argument
that is really developed
or at least started by eric sundquist
and argued that part of the issue
is this idea that the exodus right is
binding african-americans and jews to
the sort of uh really ancient kind of
history
and as many of you might recall in
exodus it's like this notion of thus
says the lord the god of israel
let my people go that they may celebrate
a feast
to me and so this becomes a kind of
um gathering call for both groups sort
of
to really think through the promise of
yahweh the promise of god
and i want to argue
that this kind of relationship right
linking
together blacks and jews through the
exodus story not the holocaust
or black suffering and death creates the
possibility right
for thinking through um texts as
lived possibilities right texas
something that's lived not
dead but also really to help us think
through the ways in which um
desperate district groups right can
actually
bracket right uh immediate social
circumstances
immediate economic circumstances and
really try
to link to kind of a narrative
um that is constant but shifting in
other words
i want to argue that blacks and jews
right have within their fingertips right
this notion of exodus
and if we read it in a kind of a
critical lens
through a kind of black feminist sort of
womanist sort of
perspective right taking into account
eric saeed's criticisms
of the exodus narrative as potentially
imperialistic but also taking into
account john leveson's account
that well maybe the exit story really
isn't about radicalization of the people
maybe it really is about
how um people become de-radicalized
right
i want to argue that what if we use this
exodus right as a way of thinking about
what does it mean to exist in the
wilderness and what does it mean
to exist um as a people who are
dispossessed
and who are displaced and if we think
about it in these terms right
we're shifting the bait away from this
idea of who's actually a chosen people
right
we bracket that and really focus on this
idea of what
how do we gain material freedom for all
human beings
because i think if we look at
particularly the works of
of king and how king uses exodus as well
as
uh rabbi abraham hesho we see how the
exodus becomes a kind of a a kind of um
grounding for a lived religion and then
lived kind of expression
that really changes how we look at text
and how we look at doctrine
and creates possibilities for looking at
narrative as something that is expansive
and a way of welcoming in rather than
using narratives
to foreclose the very possibility of
mutual dialogue and so
i want to you know abraham hesho was at
a conference
and and spoke of the ways in which
religion
right and race uh work hand in hand and
he argued
at a conference religion race in 1963
that you know what pharaoh is not dead
and part of the issue that we're facing
right particularly as
american jews but also white protestants
that we have assumed
that pharaoh is dead and that the work
of the exodus is complete
and if we look at what's happening um to
the negro in america
um you know during the late early and
late 1960s
we see right this sort of resurfacing
right of a certain kind of evil they
have abraham hespel talks about
which is racism and that when we as
religious people
do not respond to racism as as a
legitimate evil
right as something we must work against
we are turning our back to god
right and this then takes us back to
this whole idea of
of the exodus and he wants to argue that
you know when we think about religion
and race where he says look you can't
worship god
and assume that the negro is the problem
right that the negro is the aberration
of what it means to be human
and so he really wants to use
like religion and race in a very
interesting way that i think
really beckons us to really challenge
the very grounds of
of of of american origin stories right
because many of you know many of us have
been taught that look
the nation is one of you know built upon
a city on the hill think of john
winthrop
and that from that we get this idea of
american jeremiah story and of american
exceptionalism
but what hesh show is pointing to really
are the ways in which we've
used religion right within the u.s
context
in many respects to sort of reify
anti-blackness and i would even argue
anti-semitism if we go back to james
baldwin's
article right in the new york times that
blacks are not
uh anti-semitic they're anti-white and
so
part of what baldwin is saying that i
think that hesho is implicitly
aligning himself with this idea that we
have not dealt with
right the sort of lingering effects of
christianities
ongoing but shifting uses of
anti-semitic tropes
and of anti-blackness and until we begin
to
to deal with what's at the very core
of the american enterprise both heschel
and baldwin argue that we're missing the
point
and so i want us to sort of think about
this whole notion of when we think about
anti-semitism we have to also think
about anti-black racism
and we think about something like racism
we have to have anti-semitism and look
at the very
the sort of the the core origins of of
of of of of of both forms of hatred
and show how in many respects right what
connects blacks and jews is not the sort
of mythic history of you know we have
all
you know we all have gotten along we all
believe in the same things
but it's this idea of we both have a
kind of common
sort of oppression around the ways in
which our bodies right for
catholicism this idea that well well
jews are dirty so therefore they should
handle dirty money
right for white supremacy in the amount
of context this idea that you know
blacks are barbarians so on the first
level
that then becomes a way of connecting
this idea that both have
experienced a kind of um anti-humanness
right
from you know christian sort of tropes
and christian writers
but then i think if we stay at that
level in terms of
let's like look at our shared oppression
right then it gets really complicated
because
we begin then to compete in terms of
who's actually suffering more
um you know this idea well whose
holocaust is greater is it slavery or is
it the holocaust
and i want to argue that well let's
actually maintain
right this notion of the kind of shared
oppression but let's not
use it as the kind of foundation of the
relationship
let's actually then extend it to look at
how they might be exodus right
as this idea of dispossessed people
right this idea of people who
are are landless right of people who are
who are seeking a certain promise
how does that then really rethink
what it means right for us
to think about political solidarity
within the u.s
context so i want now
so i think this is important then also
because it really
allows us then the kind of theoretical
tools
to i think engage in modern society but
also to engage
what michelle modi adam call michelle
moody adams calls
what is familiar right often when we
are sort of debating about injustice
right anti-semitism sexism transphobia
we often start from what is very
familiar
and i'm not saying that's a that's a bad
starting part but i think
we can't end there and so part of what
um invoking excess narrative allows us
to do i think
is to bring in a new set of sort of
tools to think through
right um the very grounds upon which we
are exerting
right are our sense of um
outrage about injustice and so part of
what is linking then
um king and hesh was this idea of really
breaking the silence right
king argues that silence is a form of
betrayal
and so let's go back into what lessons
and can we learn
from how african americans have used
this exodus story and how i'm trying to
bring it together
one would argue that african americans
have really viewed the bible
historically as a kind of talking book
there there's a actual story in archives
of a slave who
witnessed a slave master reading this
book
and he said he literally saw the book
talking and him lewisgates
talks about this and his work signifying
monkey and and from that moment
on the slave went to the bible and
wanted the bible to talk back
and so this became a kind of trope with
an african-american sort of religious
folklore
and so when um american slaveholders
told
this story of exodus to the slaves right
and connected to this idea that you know
of paul's notion that well
your inheritance is really in heaven so
don't see this story as
liberating you now but i actually
liberate you in the future
it's interesting the slaves so well we
actually reject that story
we reject that interpretation and we
want to read the story as an example
of what god can do for one group of
people
is a reminder that what god can do for
us and so it became a way in which
they turned to the bible as a kind of
talking book as this kind of
form of engagement and this thing
created a sense of radical hermeneutics
right
and that scripture became a kind of
living text
and this is important i think because it
will force us
to really rethink both blacks and jews
in terms of
what are we holding as sacred that both
binds us to our tradition into what is
sacred
and those things are also necessary but
then how then do we allow for the very
possibility right of rupturing
that which we hold is sacred and i think
part of
um the answer and the tools for this is
thinking about
how slaves saw scripture as a kind of
living text
and then next this idea as i mentioned
before then
as a living text the slaves embrace
exodus story as a kind of narrative of
god's promise for the future and they
use this as a guide right to think
through the new testament
and to think through their own sort of
material history
in terms of enslaved people
so and from this notion they began to
build a tradition
and this in tradition include the
sorrows songs that w boyce talks about
this idea
of really uh the nation's first sort of
you know
um music that that breathed
life into the nation but also
spoke of the life of slaves
and clearly then we have the fiscal
jubilee singers and then
rather franklin and so i want to connect
this to a really interesting kind of
story in terms of how we think about
again that
texas living and this kind of dialogical
engagement
and there's a a famous song by um that
uh aretha franklin terp it's called mary
don't you weep
and and that song sort of links god's
liberating hand in the new testament
right to pharaoh's defeat and what's
also interesting is that
um the songwriter and this early slave
sort of weaved together
right both the exodus story along with
the new testament to really kind of
create
um this interesting exchange right
that links together both traditions but
then creates the possibility
for something new to emerge and again i
think it beckons to this whole idea that
when blacks and jews are working whether
whether it's at the elite level or even
at this kind of working class exchange
there's a constant kind of navigation
and part of that navigation at least on
the part of african-americans has
everything to do with this idea
of seeing the text and looking at text
in general as a kind of
um talking book and how this talking
book
book creates a kind of dialogical
exchange so i want to read part of the
lyrics to you then and
then play an excerpt from um aretha
franklin it's like whole idea oh mary
don't you weep don't you moan pharaoh's
army got drowned in the red sea oh mary
don't you weep
if i could surely would i'd stand on the
rock where moses did pharaoh's army got
drowned oh mary don't you weep
oh mary don't you leave tell martha
don't you moan listen mary and it's a
story in terms of
um what happens with lazarus and and the
rebirth
of lazarus i want to just play a quick
excerpt
of the song to kind of uh invoke right
this kind of exchange of of the singer
and the audience how it speaks to
this living tradition
and so part of what i want to show
right with thinking through um
sort of music right um and that sort of
exchanges that what we hear in terms of
the sort of the lead singer and and the
the choir and so the musicians is right
this sort of constant exchanging in
terms of
who has primary leadership role right
this idea of
trying to re-narrate a story around
um the promise right that people see
within sacred texts
and i think this in many respects speaks
to right
the ways in which blacks and jews um i
think at the core right despite the kind
of infighting and
and and the frustrations right that the
core
they are sort of navigating right um a
set of texts
to help them think through how to make
sense of the material world but in a way
that i think
if we keep this episode access as a kind
of living
ongoing sort of story that isn't dead i
think really
speaks to the ways in which um freedom
can be
fully sort of embodied and so
you know eric goldstein reminds us this
idea that you know that it's extending
from rabbi hessel that exodus is far
from being completed and so as we look
at
say the role or the rise of american
jews
during the new deal um and with sort of
the
sort of the rise of jews as they left
inner cities and
in the late 40s and 50s and moved to the
suburbs and were embraced
by you know white gentiles there is on
the one hand a story of well
clearly jews are the kind of model
minority they are very successful
and so therefore they don't experience
you know the kinds of
bigotry that african-americans have
experienced and i want to join with
with eric goldstein argue that what's
interesting is that
even with this kind of sort of
professional success right
among many american jews what he wants
to remind us is this idea that jews have
we have remained right a kind of other
well they may not have been marginalized
from these sort of the structures of
power they remain a constant
other which creates its own kind of
double consciousness right
and what we see with the rise of
charlottesville
is that that other nest is right um is
sort of materialized
in a kind of unspoken hatred an unspoken
anti-semitism
that seems to each surface right every
few decades especially when we're
experiencing some form of economic
or political trauma and i want to link
that in terms of well
what is otherness how does that link to
to african americans what lisa's
idea what du bois called really the
negro problem
and his whole idea that in the american
context right
blacks have been defined as as
a legitimate ontological problem and
the nation has been working desperately
to figure out how do we solve this
problem
and that has been one of the actually
the source
right of what sort of reifies
anti-blackness is that
people assume blacks are the problem and
so what becomes very interesting right
is that you know despite
the kinds of you know differences in
terms of economic and political success
between blacks and jews
there remains this kind of tension right
this kind of social tension around jews
as
a kind of perennial other um and you
and blacks as the kind of perennially
marginalized
people
and so as we think about the ways in
which
this marginalization
and otherness emerges i want to argue
and
again this is a work that is developing
that
we have to rethink israel and the role
of africa
right in our respective communities and
i want to join in with
vidi madimbe university and argue that
we have invented right sacred places
right
as a way to affirm what is familiar as a
way to protect us against white
supremacy
right as a way to legitimate who we are
as peoples to
to affirm our form of civilization but i
think
in doing so right we have not um
explored sort of the dangers of what it
means then to create these sacred places
that then we then lock in a moment of
history that we lock
um as sort of a model for protecting us
against
a kind of suffering a kind of death and
i think
as long as we keep these places right as
a kind of trope or source
for protection right we will not be able
to see the possibilities of how
they can open up new new possibilities
for who we are
and i think we'll continue to have right
the palestinian problem
sort of loomless large in the face when
also with africa we'll see
right the continued problems around
poverty right
and around leadership and so
what does it mean then and how is israel
reinvented in our lives and how is
africa reinventing
into our lives and so i
i mean i'll discuss this a bit later
because i'm running out of time here
but i want to bring in sort of the
rapper drake to kind of think through
for us um what does it mean to kind of
think about reinvention of not only of
who we are as a sacred people right
but reinvention and reinventing the
exodus right
as a way um to call us beyond
our sort of racial racial constructions
and to call us for what phenomenon call
a kind of new humanism
and let me just go in here one second
so as we prepare to sort of think
through um
so the grounds of hope one of the
reasons why
i i wanted to sort of end with drake is
in part to try
to invoke the ways in which reinvention
right happens all the time
and this idea of rethinking exodus right
i think is actually necessary because
i don't imagine a kind of quote grand
alliance happening again
i think the economic disparities are too
great
i think for most of my students both
white and white jews and
african-americans
they have no personal interactions they
don't live in the same neighborhoods
they don't go to the same sort of social
functions they may work together but
they don't have an intimacy
but i think if we can focus on
sort of the sacred text right and use
them as as kind of these sort of
discursive sites
for re re-exploring the ways in which um
we continue to spread our wealth or
despite our lack of wealth continue to
face a kind of
dispossession right um a kind of um
landlessness as it were a kind of
wilderness experience
i think it opens the possibility then
for using this history
not to necessarily regain an alliance if
it happens to be great
but to find useful ways within our
different different communities right
to fight against racism transphobia
right the issues that are sort of that
keep us
from becoming full the full humans that
rabbi hession
talked about and again um
there are lots of kind of i would say
pitfalls here i mean there's lots of
sort of histories that
are repulsive on both parts and we can
go through that during the discussion
but i want to focus on given the ways in
which
you know we see this resurgence of white
supremacy um
this resurgence of anti-semitism
anti-blackness
i want to figure out how then do we look
at sort of the past as a way of
remembering that kind of tony morrison's
tony morrison's way of cultivating right
we have dismantling
repairing and reimagining possibilities
i think the exodus right
is the one story that sort of links us
but still recognizes
our deep differences so thank you very
much for for
for attending and i look forward to
hearing your questions
thank you uh terence for that really
thought provoking
and um and very entertaining i have to
say
uh presentation and i it just made me
think that you know
um at the anti-semitism program we
we don't actually have many religious
studies scholars talking and it's such
like an important different way of
thinking you know we mostly have
historians political scientists
and so i thought it was just very
stimulating to have actually
um that way of thinking presented to us
um to
to um to think about you know such
an important issue so a lot of questions
um so let's just kind of dive in um
one question i had is you know
i can't help but think that one of the
obstacles to a kind of black jewish
dialogue in america comes from
a contrast in the way the two groups um
uh think about or kind of represent to
themselves
their story in america um so
you know for black people obviously
you know slavery is looming you know
extremely large
you know and this kind of you know
america
connotes you know oppression to it you
know to a large extent whereas for
jews um i think they tend to
see the ameri their history in america
as
you know itself an exodus and a kind of
liberation
you know to a problematic extent i i
just came from another
um talk earlier today about
um the history of anti-semitism in
america that i think
jews have a hard time even
facing up to themselves i think there's
a kind of tendency within
jewish historiography but also popular
jewish culture
to see america really as the promised
land
and to kind of whitewash all the
different ways
in which um it was not always the case
that america was so open
to jews to the extent that that what
happened in charlottesville
came as a total shock you know and of
course
um in pittsburgh too so i'm wondering if
you can address
those um two contrasting narratives of
what america means
no maurice that's a great question and
there's so many ways to answer it i
think
you know what's interesting is that i
think about michael stops 20 at the
roots right this idea
that for for many early sort of jewish
families was this whole idea when we
come to america right
you stay below the radar um you
recognize the opportunities but you also
recognize sort of the imminence of death
and what's also interesting for african
americans in terms of the issue around
slavery right
it's really not until the late 80s when
morrison introduces beloved that african
americans are
are publicly talking about slavery i
mean she argues that she wrote the book
in part because
black folk had buried the history and
didn't want anything to do with it
because
it was it was a public sort of mark
of their inferiority right of how
they've been captive
and a kind of a horrible history and so
when
beloved comes out i think as wendy
zailer really talks about this whole
idea of waiting are you trying to create
a new holocaust moment because
again beloved comes out as we see the
the emergence of the american holocaust
museum
and people are finally talking about the
holocaust in america sort of role in
that or
or and lack of sort of you know
stand up nests to in in the during the
war and for african-americans it was
like oh
this is what american jews are doing let
us now then begin to talk about slavery
and very interesting and
it's kind of a similar way and then
there's another moment sort of prior to
that in the 1960s
where eric sundquist is going to argue
that well black power
in some respects allows jews to say wait
a minute i can also claim
a kind of self-identity right in my
jewishness and my zionist
sort of background as a way to exert
myself so so some rabbis particularly in
in in the midwest region are are saying
i'm sorry midwest in terms of
mid-atlantic region rather are using the
black power as a way to try to ignite a
kind of
sort of public remembering of jewish
life in america
and as you say to stop whitewashing that
history so i do think so it's a kind of
a complicated history so i think on the
one hand
both groups publicly are masking
how they are internalizing and
responding to white supremacy
and i think for them asking for
different reasons right
i think for african-americans is a side
of shame
like they you know they're trying to
show
through the politics of respectability
and racial up with ideology
look we too can pull ourselves by our
bootstraps
and for american jews there's a
recognition that well i'm not white
and i'm i'm discriminated against at the
same time
right i recognize what's happening to
african-americans but i also don't want
particularly
for southern jews right who many who are
merchant owners i don't want to get
killed so there's a kind of strange kind
of silence
but yet recognition that i too am like
them so i think it's a really kind of
complicated history
but both are responding to a kind of
anti-anti-semitism
um kind of anti-blackness and both kind
of have this lingering sense of death
that's imminent
really interesting okay so here's a
question from a real
expert on the topic um cheryl greenberg
oh my god
hello oh my gosh professor grimberg
great to see you
have your question here yeah so she says
this is fascinating and persuasive
but how do we make sense of the fact
that most of the jews who were most
involved with civil rights were the
least religious
so reform leftist non-religious jews
the orthodox by contrast were nowhere to
be seen
uh focusing on religious obligations or
approaches did not seem to
tie into jewish engagement in the
movement in the pa
and the black jewish movement in the
past so how might it now
especially with more jews and others
identifying as secular
well well that's a great question of
course by the great scholar thank you so
much
um i think you're right and and what
i've been trying to figure out is
what role then how does abraham hesh
also
play sort of writ large right within so
the jewish community and and i do
think we see in terms of at least in dc
some of the
conservative rabbis are actually
speaking out in favor right
in in sermons and maybe they're not
present and body
but some of their sermons are indicating
that they're they're recognizing what's
happening to african-americans in the
60s
and there's a kind of willingness at
least to articulate it that
sort of concern within their sermons now
i think you're right in terms of
the south is a very different kind of
story right there's a sense in which
very real you know threat of their uh
fear of their death and
so what does it mean for this moment
well i know the new york times that this
great sort of picture of acidic jews who
healthy signs of black lives matter and
i think we are at a different moment now
where
um conservative jews in particular are
recognizing right
sort of the limits of sort of the
benefits of whiteness right
because of this kind of othering um and
i do think
when we look at what happened in in
ferguson in missouri
that a number of conservative jews from
the ground that you know our rabbi
at georgetown gave me great anecdotal
stories about this so i i think
but the problem is i think now i think
there's a different problem i think
we're seeing more of the quote
leadership right within um
the jewish community on the grounds of
black lives matter and conversely we're
seeing
less leadership in the black community
with black lives matter more in terms of
the youthfulness so
and so i think we've got to figure out
how do we make these bridges and i'm
actually late today later this evening
speaking to
the hebrew congregation um in dc my
colleague and i jacques are going to
talk through some of these issues but i
think now they should becomes well how
do
how do we like transfer this information
or or the
or sort of the activism from sort of the
leadership
the rabbis to the actual sort of
congregation and that becomes a hard
part because my colleague jacques says
it's this whole idea of how do you
reckon with this sort of history right
rabbi
steinloff who was the the rabbi at the
conservative
israel here in um in dc where the late
ruth ginsburg attended
had this great sermon a couple years ago
on you know
jews have to recognize they are not
white and return to judaism and again
for people who are not religious this
whole sense of wait are you saying i
need to
become more religious in order to have
this sort of social justice sort of
um ethos and and activism and he's like
yes because you're jews
and you have to recognize that that's
why you're here so and i have a problem
with in part because it speaks to the
idea well
there's a kind of burden then for being
chosen that
and are you saying then that jews have
more responsibility
right to advocate for anti or to
fighting against
blackness because of right this weight
of being what it means to be jewish
according to
this particular kind of belief so i hope
i know it it scratches your question
cheryl but
i was i'm still thinking through but
thank you i think it was a good question
yeah i mean it's such an
interesting question the question of
orthodox jews because
you know as you said you know um there
used to be much more
contact i think between blacks and jews
and now
it's really orthodox jews in certain
neighborhoods in brooklyn who have the
most day-to-day
contact and it's such an interesting
thought like would they be
more receptive to a religious you know
approach
to dialogue or or less you know um
it would be really interesting to know
how they would
you know hear what you're you know
saying about exodus
anyway um so one other question um
i had is um whether
you can trace historically some of the
kind of decline of dialogue to changes
within the black
church um in general um
you know over the last like let's say 30
years so and maybe
you know do you see a kind of um is that
is the black church playing a kind of
uh less of a role now in
in shaping and uh you know promoting
dialogue
what do you think well that's a great
question i mean when i
as i'm getting calls anecdotally i'm
finding that
it's really i'm getting calls from
jewish communities i think jewish
community leaders who want to talk with
this issue
and when i talk to colleagues and and
peers who are african-americans are like
well why are we having this why do you
want to talk about blacks and jews
you know they're white there's no
connection right they're successful
we're not
and so it's this interesting kind of uh
um
a shift in terms of the conversation i
think and part of it has to do i think
with again i'm not trying to blame it on
the boogeyman but the ways in which
social structures right force in many
cases force jews
out of urban areas right we have the
case in boston where
literally bankers and and legislators
says look we want to reclaim
uh back bay area which is mostly
african-american
um and we went actually moved into
roxbury well that's where most of the
jews were living was like okay well
we're going to basically go and tell
jews look the blacks are coming they're
going to rape your women and you're
probably about you're going to go down
better get out of here and so some
people are like oh i think you're right
and so this interesting thing where
you have this happening in in roxbury
you also have it happen in philadelphia
that there's these shifts in urban areas
that sort of forcing the
um american white jews out of these
areas
which is then basically leaving this
black enclave and some of these black
enclaves are buying and purchasing old
synagogues and converting them into
churches
and so there's a lot of exchange here
but something happens i think
with the end of black black power
right where we see this kind of
explosion over israel
and then we have this period between the
60s and 80s when we see
again a rise of black mares and major
cities
you know like cleveland like atlanta and
dc
iron is that many of the mayors their
campaign managers
were jewish colleagues and friends right
um
jesse jackson right famous anti-semitic
comments behind me town
you know his his campaign manager was
was an american jew
right who was really interested in
trying to sort of re-galvanize the 60s
and so we have this moment
between 60s and 70s where blacks are
occupying public spaces
but there's a huge decline right in
terms of um
sort of black wealth and there's a kind
of stagnancy there
and there's also a sense in which black
mayors are having to appeal right
to the business community right which is
white gentile and jewish so this creates
these really kind of strange
relationships right again
you're dealing with with american jews
right who you know there's some kind of
there's some kind of commonality but
they're not in your community anymore
now they really are simply
right the face behind the building
chronicle or they're your physician so
it really changes the dynamics so i
think
for many of professional american jews
you know they remember the stories right
around brad heschel and king
and then for african americans between
like the 70s and 80s with the riser
crack epidemic
they don't see that right they see a
group of people who have abandoned them
and so the idea of having a conversation
it's not really present
now will the leaders have have the
conversation oh yeah when i call the
the the ministers oh they're they're
gladly have a conversation
but the congregants are like i don't
know what do we get out of this and so
and that's where
my colleagues are kind of stuck in terms
of how do we get people in there
particularly in black churches
right who want to have this conversation
now in terms of black lives matter
what's interesting is
a number of the young advocates are
saying look we'll talk to
white jews if they align with our
political ideology or we have
we have some overlap let's have a
conversation so i'm finding that's where
people
interested if our galvanizing and
forming kind of coalitions right
are in these sort of extensions of black
lives matter right which has a very
interesting history as well so
in some respects you know even though
i'm arguing for a retrieval of exodus
the religious space right is not where
it's necessarily happening
but i still want to argue that that
language of exodus in terms of
rethinking dispossession
right uh wilderness allows us then to
deal with sort of contemporary issues
right around
palestine right around this idea refugee
crisis i think can galvanize both groups
even though we're no longer in many
cases in the same communities or
worshiping together or or dining
together in the same social clubs
okay we're running out of time so i want
i'm going to ask you like two final
questions and you can kind of
answer both either so uh one
you know from the audience which picks
up on something um
that you've talked about about you know
1967
as this turning point both because of
the black power movement and also
um the six day war in israel the
beginning
of um the occupation and you know
whether you see like you know is
you know intersectionality for instance
now like an
obstacle to um i think a lot of jews see
that as an
obstacle um and how how you
you know think about that and then
another question about
um the nation of islam so to what extent
is your model predicated on
a kind of jewish christian dialogue and
how would
um you know uh black muslims see that
question and see the whole exodus model
no both very good questions and i'll
start with the i guess the hardest one
first in the nation of islam
i mean i'd argue that i i see this as a
kind of a post-christian
kind of model right in terms of really
taking exodus story
outside of the confines of sort of what
it means to have a sacred text
you know sacred book and really using it
in terms of
public deliberation right using the kind
of images
right not to um in to reimagine a kind
of exceptionalism or kind of chosen us
right
but as a way to think about um in some
respects
those who are not very visible right you
know in other words
i'm trying to think of a model of how
then do we um ignite even those who
are wealthy or don't have wealth right
to see that they
haven't there's a shared interest in
terms of if you believe in humanity
right
or some form of humanity can we then
agree upon
right that we've got to deal with issue
refugee crisis right because it speaks
to
right the very depths of who we are what
we think we imagine so
so somewhere in some respects i want to
take out excess from the kind of
religious sacred space
and look at it in terms of a kind of
working political vocabulary
and you know intersectionality is really
interesting my colleague and i
we are really beginning to wrestle this
now because look for jewish americans
it's kind of an effacement right
it does not work and for african
americans it becomes a way
of recognizing right the multiplicities
and differences right in terms of
gender sexuality right in class that
then allow us to see
the kind of the nuances of
anti-blackness and so intersectionality
i
works for us and so now i think we need
to have coverage in terms of
so why isn't it working for american
jews and
i i wonder is the question around um
is what's is not working that question
of whiteness right
and thinking through this idea of really
uh exploring sort of the conception of
whiteness and the ways in which
you know some american jews are are
clinging to that and really i wanted to
bring in
baltimore and say look you know do you
want to choose whiteness or choose what
it means or just choose to be human
because
whiteness is a kind of social
construction but it's a real cultural
construction we think about the early
citizenship laws
right in order to for the immigrants
early immigrants to gain citizenship
right in terms of
particularly south south asians who came
they had to know we're actually
we're not black we're white we're part
of the aryan race you have to include us
as citizens and so
there's a real uh material good to being
white
historically and so i so i understand
part of that kind of
that concern okay well
you know we could really go on all day
um all night you have another talk you
have to give
um and i know people have to go eat
dinner so we will stop it there
um and just say thank you so much uh
terence for that really really
stimulating um
and really just very smart dialogue so
thank you very much um i will clap on
behalf
of everyone else so thank you for coming
thank you for the invitation and i had a
great time thank you